collège visitation laverdière cours de
géographie troisième année aujourd'hui
le volcanisme en support de cette vidéo
veuillez consulter le syllabus de
géographes 6 à la page 22
le manuel de géographie l'attitude
troisième les pages sont ensuite à 201
et la place sur les planches géologie la
terre qu'il y ait séismes et volcans son
nom de d petit rappel sur la structure
de la terre avec l'asthénosphère la
partie la plus visqueuse ici et la
lithosphère la partie solide extérieur
qui reprend la croûte terrestre et la
croûte océanique pour différentes
raisons
des éléments liquides du de magma qui
sont ici dans l'asthénosphère vont
remonter un certain moment en raison de
certains facteurs vers la surface
ils vont ici se concentrer dans ce qu'on
appelle une chambre magmatique
et quand la pression se deviendra
vraiment trop forte
il y aura une échappée de magma qui va
provoquer une éruption volcanique en
surface le magma une fois apparu à l'air
libre en surface devient de la lave
évidemment cette lave va s'écouler le
long d'un cône qui va constituer couche
après couche qui vont se solidifier qui
va constituer le volcan donc en fait le
volcan c'est la superposition les voit
bien ici de différentes couches de
l'aavb qui se sont solidifiés les unes
après les autres jusqu'à former un cône
il existe plusieurs causes d'apparition
des volcans tous les volcans
n'apparaisse pas pour la même raison la
première cause c'est le volcanisme de
subduction nous l'avons déjà vu au cou
le mouvement des plaques tectoniques
fait qu'un certainement une plaque
océanique plonge en dessous d'une plaque
continentale ou d'une
plaque océanique en s'enfonçant dans le
magma chaud les roches ici fondre entre
en fusion des gaz s'échappe et vienne
provoquer ici d'importantes pressions
sur la lithosphère et un certain moment
va céder et va permettre l'échappement
du magma et va donc constituer un volcan
vous avez ici la même chose de l'autre
côté
donc c'est le volcanisme de subduction
deuxième type de volcanisme le vote
khalife de divergence qui va apparaître
au niveau des dorsales et des riffs là
ici les deux plaques ses cartes et au
sein de cet écartement évidemment j'ai
un sol qui n'existe plus finalement
qu'est directement en contact avec
l'asthénosphère et donc le magma ici
vale directement s'échapper cela peut
être le fait de volcans sous marins où
ça peut être aussi au sein darif
continental donc quand deux plaques
continentales ces castes et laisse
apparaître des volcans sur toute la
ligne de fracture
c'est ce qui se passe par exemple en
islande est une grande île devenue
petite île mais qui contient beaucoup de
volcans donc été une grande île
volcanique et enfin la troisième cause
de volcanisme d'apparition des volcans
ce sont les points chauds ou hotspot
en fait comment ça se passe à certains
points de la lithosphère il ya des zones
plus fragiles qui vont céder par rapport
au magma chaud qui exercent toujours une
pression et qu'ils vont constituer en
fait des volcans mais qui sont vraiment
perdu au milieu des plaques qui ne
correspondent pas à une zone entre deux
plaques en fonction du type de roche qui
sont en fusion
on va avoir l'apparition de deux types
de volcans complètement différent d'un
côté il y a des volcans effusif comme
par exemple les volcan hawaïen ou le
stromboli
itéra n'est qu'ils ont de la lave très
puisque notre est puisque ce très
liquide donc là là va s'écouler vraiment
s'écouler le long du volcan comme comme
du miel qui dégouline ray d'une biscotte
et ses volcans là sont très
spectaculaires parce qu'évidemment on
voit jaillir la lave encore en fusion
mais ils sont très peu dangereux pour
l'homme parce qu'ils sont en réalité
très prévisible la lave continue de
s'écouler
évidemment si on s'approche de la lave
s'est risqué mais si on est à bonne
distance de ceux-ci de celle ci il n'y a
pas de problème par contre il ya les
volcans explosif et la lave est beaucoup
plus visqueuse donc elle a beaucoup de
mal à remonter dans le code elle se
bloque et les gaz sont emprisonnés à
certains endroits et vont s'accumuler
jusqu'à former une pression vraiment
très importante
un certain moment la roche base cèdent
parce que la pression est devenue trop
importante et les gazons s'échapper
d'une vraiment et c'est vraiment une
explosion spectaculaire qui fait
énormément de bruit et qui va en même
temps entraîné d'énormes cendres un
nuage de cendres qui va s'étaler sur
toute la région à plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres qui correspondent en fait
bouchon de roche 1 qu' une part étant
l'instrument voilà va jaillir avec avec
ses roches et vont former vraiment une
explosion alors certains volcans sont
une demande et une puissance supérieure
à la bombe atomique
quelques petites remarques alors nous on
a en tête bien sûr les volcans les
grands volcans dont on vient de parler
mais les principaux volcans sont d'abord
des volcans sous marins qui
correspondent à des zones l'écartement
des deux femmes des zones de subduction
il arrive il arrive très fréquemment que
les volcans soit sous l'eau donc ça
donne ceci en fait la lave dès qu'elle
sort bine est refroidie et des gaz
dégagent des gaz de manière importante
lorsqu'ils sont aux frais des anciens
volcans vont finalement s'éteindre ce
sont comme les volcans d'auvergne qui ne
sont plus du tout
actif parce que la plaque la plaque
tectonique continue à se déplacer donc
ici on voit bien qu'on était sûr de
volcanisme de points chauds à chaque
fois eu un point chaud qui a fait qui a
créé un volcan mais la plaque se
déplaçant belle points chauds s'est
déplacé et ça fait vraiment une ligne de
volcans mais ici comme voilà comme le
point chaud s'est déplacé du fait de
l'avancement des plaques ses volcans la
de son plutôt actif et ne le seront plus
jamais c'est la même chose pour certains
un archipel volcanique voyez ici j'ai
différents archipels donc fait son
rachat fois d'anciens volcans qui se
sont déplacés en même temps que la
plaque et qui ne correspondent plus à
l'endroit où il y avait la remontée de
malmont donc ils sont est en quelques
sortes
il ya d'autres phénomènes qui sont liées
à l'activité volcanique comme les
sources d'eau chaude évidemment l'eau va
être chauffé par le magasin ou alors
encore les geysers donc là c'est de
l'eau chaude et qui sévit sous pression
et a certainement qui sort du sol comme
ça on a au parc de yellowstone au
nord-est et ouest par des états unis
ainsi qu'en dise maroc notamment la
vidéo est à sa fin je vous propose la
préparation pour le prochain coup ici
vous allez avoir les deux cartes auquel
vous avez déjà été confronté c'est la
page sanglante de la classe la place 14e
édition
ce que je vous demande s est
d'identifier trois volcans et si vous
avez sur cette planche si ici tous les
différents rôles quand vous allez me
identifié trois volcans qui
correspondent aux trois causes que nous
avons vu dans cette vidéo
donc il ya les hotspots il y a les le
volcanisme de subduction et le
volcanisme de divergences au sein des
dorsales et bien essayé de me retrouver
sur ces 2 4 les différents volcan qui
sont attachés à ces différents cause
si vous avez des questions envoyez moi
un mail ou croisés - dans la cour de
récréation jour expliquerait cette
préparation qui est dans vos cordes et
je vous souhaite voir préparé par
bonne fin de journée et à bientôt